en parler nous sommes avec l'autre
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude blanche
maison merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france pour bien comprendre quel
est l'enjeu de cette rencontre entre
valdimir poutine pour nikol pashinian je
crois que nicole pas de chignons et est
venu chercher un soutien le soutien de
vladimir poutine sur deux points
d'abord sur un pont humanitaire très
important pour la population arménienne
et ensuite un soutien politique en vue
les élections alors le soutien
humanitaire c'est dans l'accord de
cessez-le-feu du 9 10 novembre dernier
il ya une clause qui prévoit bien sûr
comme généralement après un accord de
cessez-le-feu la libération de tous les
prisonniers de tous les prisonniers de
tous les otages de tous les détenus
malheureusement le le monsieur alief n'a
pas libéré les prisonniers arménien et
patxi n'y en a obtenu aujourd'hui le
soutien de poutine pour demander à bas
coût que les prisonniers arménien soit
libéré je crois que c'est un point très
important pour la population arménienne
et puis alors deuxièmement comme il va y
avoir des élections
comme vous l'avait dit au mois de juin
évidemment pas de chignan veut montrer
qu' elle est en bons rapports avec
vladimir poutine
et ceci n'est pas tout à fait évident il
revient de loin monsieur pas de chignons
puisqu'il est arrivé au pouvoir en 2018
il y a trois ans à la tête d'une sorte
de révolution de velours d'une
contestation du pouvoir établi avec
lequel moscou entretenait de bons
rapports et par conséquent il a soulevé
des soupçons de subversion à moscou cela
dit il s'est montré homme d'état
raisonnable courageux même puisqu'il a
dû accepter cet accord du nymphée et 10
novembre dernier l'armée arménienne
était était battu elle avait sous-estimé
ses forces et est gravement sous-estimé
l'armée qui se battait contre elle est
finalement évidemment monsieur pas de
signe en a bien a dû reconnaître qu'il
n'avait pas le choix et la signer cet
accord avec alief et avec le président
poutine lorsqu'il est revenu à erevan
il est il a évidemment été pris à partie
violemment par l'opposition bien sûr
mais aussi par l'armée qui cherchait à
se dédouaner de sa défaite par l'église
même et par une grande partie de la
population arménienne
par conséquent il a dû faire face il a
fait face il a tenu bon et je crois que
le président poutine lui en sais gré
donc dans le faux aujourd'hui il a
montré qu' il était un candidat comme
d'autres qu'il était probablement
acceptable sans doute comme d'autre part
par le kremlin
comment s'applique à 5 ans maison
l'accord de cessez-le-feu haut karabakh
conclu le 10 novembre 2020
alors à part le point sur la libération
des prisonniers par le verbe ajjan il ya
des points qui s'applique correctement
comme par exemple les clauses
territoriales qui sont très précises
puisque l'accord prévoit la remise à la
verveine gens d'un certain nombre de
districts qui avait été conquis par
l'arménie en 1940 en 94 en réalité et
qui constituait une sorte de zone tampon
entre le haut karabakh peuplé de 150
mille arméniens et l'arménie proprement
dit
l'accord prévoit également que 2000
soldats russes jouent le rôle de force
de maintien de la paix et par conséquent
dans les transferts de populations qui
accompagnent les transfère de
territoires qui sont toujours des
tragédies humanitaires
et bien cette force de la paix et cette
sphère et le moins de violence possible
et puis en deuxième lieu elle est
chargée d'assurer la liberté de
circulation dans le couloir de latchine
qui était une route en réalité qui va de
l'arménie haut karabakh était un
véritable cordon ombilical pour la
survie du haut karabagh donc elle assure
cette liberté de circulation
en revanche l'accord prévoit la création
d'un autre corridor tout à fait dans le
sud de l'arménie pour relier une
province de l'arménie qui se trouve
séparé qu'une province pardon une
province qui se trouve séparé de 202
majeure partie de son territoire et donc
cette nouvelle route ce nouveau chemin
de fer peut-être reste à adé à dessiner
reste à tracer à concevoir et aussi à
financer ça ce n'est pas du tout faits
donc il ya des points qui sont
appliquées d'autres moins et évidemment
les trois gouvernements ont désigné
trois vice-premiers ministres pour
assurer le suivi de façon à avoir une
un suivi très opérationnelle de des
clauses qui sont prévus dans cet accord
du 10 novembre dernier alors russie
arménie
peut-on parler d'un partenariat pour
l'avenir oui vous avez parlez dans votre
sujet des aspects militaires bien sûr il
y en a et d'ailleurs il ya une base
militaire russe en arménie mais il ya
aussi d'autres aspects notamment la
construction d'infrastructures dans le
domaine des transports dans le domaine
de l'énergie et
génial a mis probablement le président
poutine au pied du mur en lui demandant
si la russie serait en mesure de
construire une centrale nucléaire pour
fabriquer l'électricité puisque le pays
évidemment un déficit d'énergie
je ne sais pas quelle réponse il a il a
obtenu mais en effet ce sont dans ces
domaines clés que l'arménie voudrait
avoir aussi une coopération avec la
russie
et puis par ailleurs l'arménie a deux
types de coopération multilatérale dans
lesquelles la russie joue un rôle clé
dans le domaine de la sécurité
c'est l'organisation du traité sur la
sécurité et la coopération qui date d'il
ya une vingtaine d'années et qui prévoit
une clause d'assistance mutuelle au cas
où l'un des pays est attaqué c'est
d'ailleurs cette clause d'assistance
mutuelle qui a fait que l'azerbaïdjan
n'a pas attaquer le territoire de l'art
mineur proprement dit il a attaqué le
haut karabakh et la zone intermédiaire
qui était occupé par l'arménie en
deuxième lieu
l'arménie fait partie de l'union
économique eurasiatique qui a été créé
il ya quelques années par vladimir
poutine qui comporte également le
kazakhstan la vielle russie
l'ouzbékistan et c'est à peu près tout
et qui a prévu d'organiser une zone
d'union douanière
ça veut dire une intégration économique
quand même assez poussées et l'arménie
qui est un pays assez pauvres risquent
d'avoir des difficultés à respecter les
clauses de cette union douanière
mais en tout état de cause elles jouent
le jeu dans l'hôtel c'est comme dans
l'union économique eurasienne leur
asiatiques elles jouent le jeu d'un
partenaire de la russie alors il faut
quand même bien dire que par ailleurs
l'arménie a conclu en 2010 7,1
un accord de coopération globale avec
l'union européenne
peut-être est-ce la démonstration que ça
n'est pas tout à fait contradictoires
merci claude manche les ans expert en
relations internationales